لا يمل التاريخ من اعاده حكاياته التي ظن
الناس انها جزء من الماضي فهذا العجوز هجر
قبل 75 عاما وها هم احفاد مهجر يضربون له
موعدا اخر مع التهجير
والترويع اجينا من جبالي
يابا ماشي من جبالي له هي ساعات
ومكسور لقد صبت اسرائيل هنا اكثر من 3 الف
طن من المتفجرات وهو ما يعادل عده قنابل
نوويه حسب منظمات
حقوقيه هذه الحقائق جرحت الضمير الكوني
فخرج الناس شرقا وغربا في مظاهرات لم يعرف
التاريخ الحديث لها مثيلا اهتزت شوارع
وبحت حناجر ضيقا بالظلم وراجع اقوام
خلاصات فكريه عاشوا عليها طويلا لكن كل
ذلك لم يقنع حلفاء المحتل بمجرد الدعوه
لوقف اطلاق النار حتى رئيس وزراء كندا
المعروف ببلاغته في مجال الحقوق انزلق
لسانه ربع كلمه للمطالبه بوقف اطلاق النار
فتراجع حالا كانه نطق
محرما لم يكتفي حلفاء الاحتلال بالامتناع
عن الدعوه لوقف اطلاق النار بل اصبحوا
يسمون مظاهرات مواطنيهم الداعيه لوقف
العدوان بمظاهرات
الكراهيه
ثمت صيغه واحده لوصف هذه المظاهرات انها
مظاهرات
الكراهيه ياتي هذا والعالم يرى الاحتلال
يهدد بمحو المستشفيات بعد محاصرتها اسابيع
فهذا الناطق باسم جيش الاحتلال يقف طالبا
من العالم الاستماع الى مكالمات تثبت وجود
قاده المقاومه تحت
المستشفيات قد قالها الذين من قبلهم وهم
يتجهزون لغزو العراق ثم اعترفوا لاحقا ان
كل ذلك كان هراء عندنا استفسارات
بسيطه ها اللن
مال الجماعه عدوان الاحتلال على القطاع
تصاحبه حرب اعلاميه هائله فاسرائيل وهي
اسطوره في الذهن قبل ان تكون دوله في
الواقع تتعمد فضاع الصور الاتيه من غزه
لينسى الناس صور السابع من اكتوبر تلك
الصور التي كشفت هشاشه الاحتلال المتمرس
خلف الجذ والقرى المحصنه كما كشفت زيف
سرديته الاخلاقيه عند اول
اختبار كل شيء جائز لهم اذا لما لا وكثير
من قاده اسرائيل كما قال احدهم ذات مره لا
يؤمنون بوجود الله لكنهم يؤمنون انه جعلهم
شعب الله المختار ومنحهم البلاد المقدسه
كذلك الله